hola
[Música]
qué es lo que nos define como hombres
normalmente lo asociamos al concepto de
masculinidad pero que es la masculinidad
bueno la masculinidad son las calidades
conductas y roles asociados a los
hombres y sin embargo somos conscientes
de que este concepto ha evolucionado que
dependiendo del momento de la historia o
el lugar algunos elementos han asumido
mayor o menor importancia algunas
características nos vienen inclusive
desde la prehistoria y otras se
incorporan y adaptan el concepto de lo
masculino vienen y van como la moda
la gran mayoría de las sociedades ha
tenido roles separados para hombres y
mujeres y por lo general son los hombres
los que ejercitan el control y la figura
de poder en el grupo social y esta
lógica de blanco y negro que se supone
como un complemento muchas veces ha
creado desigualdad
por mucho tiempo se ha considerado que
el género lo determina la biología y hoy
en día tenemos autores como john money o
judith water que opinan que el género y
por lo tanto la masculinidad y la
feminidad son construcciones sociales y
esta capacidad de construir y
reconstruir identidades de género y sus
relaciones no es nueva tanto en las
sociedades antiguas como en las actuales
se ha demostrado que ni el dominio
masculino o el concepto de las
diferencias entre hombres y mujeres ha
sido un rasgo indispensable de humanidad
por ejemplo el cuido de los niños
históricamente se ha relegado a las
mamás sin embargo hoy en día cada vez
más hombres sienten la necesidad de ser
parte de ese proceso cuando hablábamos
de rasgos masculinos como el coraje
físico la fuerza y la determinación los
cuales los individuos pueden poseer en
muchas formas sobre actividades como por
ejemplo los deportes solemos pensar que
son exclusivos del hombre sin embargo
estas ideas rasgos y actitudes no son
exclusivas ya que hay mujeres que se
adhieren a estas creencias y formas de
actuar
por lo que al final lo que nos hace más
o menos masculinos es lo que la cultura
indica osea que sea especialmente
apropiado y deseable en hombres y niños
por eso más bien en vez de preguntarnos
qué significa ser masculino nos
deberíamos de plantear la pregunta como
qué tipos de hombres queremos ser
he hablado de hombres no de hombres
hasta la fecha en la mayoría de las
sociedades modernas los hombres juegan
el rol de cazadores y guerreros esto ha
sido así desde el inicio de la sociedad
y la civilización
cazadores y guerreros
también ocupamos las posiciones de poder
y ejercemos la autoridad típicamente los
hombres de alto estatus social cumplen y
están atados a un estricto código que se
relaciona con el honor y la
responsabilidad
las ideas de caballerosidad que tenemos
tienen su origen en los códigos de
conducta de los caballeros de la edad
media y los conceptos del buen pastor la
responsabilidad del señor feudal con sus
siervos etcétera que además alimentan la
imagen del patriarca la cabeza masculina
de una familia extendida que ejerce el
control y el dominio sobre sus miembros
mujeres y hombres jóvenes también
de hecho patriarcado de forma literal
significa el gobierno de los padres
históricamente este término ha sido
utilizado para designar un tipo de
organización social en que la autoridad
la ejerce el barón jefe de familia dueño
del patrimonio del que formaban parte de
los hijos la esposa los esclavos los
bienes que a los esclavos porque este
concepto viene desde los griegos y los
romanos la familia es claro está una de
las instituciones básicas de este orden
social
gerda lerner en 1986 lo ha definido como
un sentido más amplio como la
manifestación e institucionalización del
dominio masculino sobre las mujeres
niños y niñas de la familia que tiene
una ampliación ese dominio sobre las
mujeres en la sociedad en general
y en la actualidad
estamos absolutamente claros de que un
hombre que se percibe fuerte físicamente
mentalmente osado y con capacidades de
liderazgo tiende a dominar cualquier
grupo social y ejercer su poder sobre
otros esto es lo que se llama el macho
alfa y suele tener un estatus social
alto existen otras versiones más suaves
de masculinidad que incluyen al sensible
al new age al metrosexual al softbol y
variaciones son culturales como el
deportista el rebelde y el nerd
los hombres nos adherimos a estas
versiones de masculinidad y accederemos
a diferentes niveles de estatus social y
autoridad sobre otros hombres y mujeres
aquí quisiera recalcar que por ejemplo
este tipo de diferenciación se vuelve
muy clara para todos nosotros en el
momento en que entramos a la escuela en
la escuela vemos que nosotros nos
adherimos a algunos de estos tipos de
masculinidades podríamos haber sido el
matón de la clase podríamos haber sido
el deportista podríamos haber sido el
nerd podríamos haber sido él el chiquito
de la maestra etcétera etcétera todas
estas
digamos etiquetas sociales se empiezan a
socializar desde muy temprana edad y muy
sutilmente
bueno ya hablando del tema de la
masculinidad
la otra pregunta que se me viene acá es
si existe un privilegio masculino
muchas veces se habla de que los hombres
tenemos un privilegio en que las mujeres
no lo tienen y esto crea bastante
adicción
bueno en nuestras sociedades y en
nuestras relaciones interpersonales
existen códigos estructuras culturales y
sociales de poder que definen en alguna
medida la posición social de las
personas y cómo interactuamos estas
estructuras pueden favorecer a
determinadas personas o grupos el
privilegio masculino en la forma en que
los hombres reciben ventajas y
oportunidades que las mujeres no
como estas las recibimos desde el
nacimiento a partir de la simple
constatación del sexo y no las hemos
solicitado que nos hacen normales
invisibles y cotidianas
ahora bien esto no significa que seamos
malos ni siquiera sexistas simplemente
significa que hemos recibido ciertas
ventajas que otros no pueden tener y de
las que puede que ni siquiera seamos
conscientes como salir a la calle sin
sufrir acoso poder viajar solos etcétera
etcétera
pero
todos los hombres tienen ventajas sobre
todas las mujeres pues no necesariamente
y para qué es para poder entender esto
hay que entender el término de la
intersección alidad que es un concepto
desarrollado por las feministas a
finales de los 80s que explican como el
género la etnia la clase la orientación
sexual la discapacidad y otras
categorías sociales son construidas y se
interrelacionan y explican no sólo por
la identidad propia y las relaciones con
otros sino en fundamental en las
discriminaciones vividas y acumuladas
por los grupos sociales
es decir el concepto de intersección
alidad evidencia en los sistemas de
opresión dominación o discriminación
por eso la intersección alidad no sólo
afecta a los privilegios que tenemos
también los que no el privilegio y la
discriminación es una moneda de dos
caras
la mayoría de los ejemplos del
privilegio masculino los vemos tan
normal es que nos cuesta tomar
conciencia de ellos reconocerlos o
verlos al menos con otra luz
vamos a poner el ejemplo de la
promiscuidad sexual
nuestras actitudes hacia los hombres
promiscuos nos hacen verlos como
masculinos audaces viniles fuertes
siempre dispuestos a tener sexo mientras
que las mujeres pro mismos las solemos
ver con desprecio y sin respeto y este
ejemplo se extiende al uso del lenguaje
vamos a ver un ejemplo
significa ser un zorro
y por contraparte que significa ser una
zorra
ahora bien en el lugar de trabajo los
hombres que hablan en reuniones y
expresan su opinión abiertamente a un
grupo a menudo son vistos como líderes
al contrario a las mujeres que hablan se
les llama agresivas abandonadas brujas y
tantas otras cosas a los hombres se les
puede escuchar más que a las mujeres se
ha demostrado por medio de estudios que
los hombres hablan el 75 por ciento del
tiempo en las reuniones y que las
mujeres tienden a tener más probabilidad
de ser interrumpidas por sus compañeros
de trabajo masculinos esto es lo que se
conoce como el manes playing
no significa que esto ocurre porque
seamos horriblemente sexistas es solo
que hay ciertas cosas que están tan
arraigadas en nuestra sociedad debido a
años y siglos de patriarcado
ahora bien teniendo en cuenta el
concepto de lo masculino y teniendo en
cuenta el concepto del privilegio
masculino tiene esto alguna relación con
la violencia que reciben las mujeres
bueno yo quisiera hablar desde mi
perspectiva personal
siempre que vemos en las noticias
femicidios violaciones y maltratos
violentos contra mujeres y niñas nos
indignamos
y solemos pensar y sentir que estos
actos repudiables no van con nosotros
digo con nosotros como hombres
y entonces alzamos la voz para condenar
a los despreciables individuos que nos
cometen
algunas veces hasta ponemos marcos en
nuestras redes sociales para dejar claro
que nosotros no hemos venido al mundo a
matarlas y violarlas sino que más bien
venimos a amarla y cuidarlos
queremos demostrar a toda costa que
nosotros no somos esos
pero es precisamente porque el proceso
de socialización de la violencia es tan
cotidiano tan normal y tan enraizado en
nuestros prejuicios en las formas en que
nos hemos educado y por las estructuras
que sostienen nuestros privilegios que
nos cuestan mucho como hombres darnos
cuentas que no sólo tenemos una
responsabilidad con estos hechos
extremos
sino que también hubiéramos podido
incidir en la sociedad con lo que
hacemos pero sobre todo con lo que
dejamos de hacer
y lo primero que debemos entender es que
la violencia es un continuo y por eso se
compara con un espiral
para que la violencia se materializa se
debe normalizar e invisibilizar así
suben intensidad y se pasa al otro nivel
es por eso que es muy importante
entender que aunque nosotros no
permitamos la violencia radical del
femicida o el violador si hemos
participado
en los procesos iniciales en el origen
de su naturalización en donde estos
sujetos validan esas violencias
progresivas
cuando se cuenta un chiste machista se
habla mal de una mujer porque nos parece
que no cumple con el rol que le
corresponde o se comparten fotos de
mujeres desnudas como mercancía estamos
dando la oportunidad a estos sujetos a
que suban en el siguiente escalón de la
violencia
pero es que no sólo se trata de hacer
los chistes en los comentarios o pasar
las fotos todos conocemos a alguien o
inclusive nosotros hemos sido ese
alguien que lo ha hecho se trata de lo
más común no hacer nada
desde nuestro privilegio y asumiendo
roles y mandatos de lo que es lo
masculino vemos normal estos
comportamientos o peor aún no nos
atrevemos a cuestionar los
porque estaríamos cuestionando nuestra
masculinidad de forma personal y
adelante de otros hombres
y en esto la actitud que deberíamos de
tomar con nosotros mismos y con nuestros
amigos colegas y familiares es la de
invitarnos no a cruzarnos
y cuando digo invitarnos es invitarnos a
tener oportunidades para reflexionar de
visualizar y entender cómo estas
dinámicas estructurales invisibles y
normales no sólo afectan a las mujeres
también nos afectan a los hombres
tener nuestros espacios de reflexión y
diálogo tanto a lo interno como al
externo
tener el valor como hombres de poder
admitir que tenemos un privilegio que
genera injusticia y que puede generar
violencia y que tiene el potencial de
tener un poder asesino que como hombres
podemos hacernos responsables de lo que
hacemos lo que decimos no solo como
individuos también como grupo todos
tenemos a ese amigo que necesitan en las
cosas de manera diferente y nosotros
podemos ayudarle
porque estamos convencidos de que el
aire ver la diversidad la empatía y la
solidaridad podemos ser más grandes y
más justos y finalmente tal vez lo más
importante más felices
porque nosotros también vamos a hacer
más felices permitiendo los espacios
emociones y conductas que nos dejen
compartir no sólo la responsabilidad
también el poder y el amor
vemos como precisamente saliendo de esos
límites de la masculinidad hegemónica
podemos actuar directamente en el lugar
donde se construye esa violencia
porque todos los hombres agresores
construyeron y validaron su concepto de
lo masculino entre hombres
como padre de una víctima de femicidio y
como hombre he tratado de entender cómo
es que un sujeto llega al convencimiento
de que tiene el poder para matar a otro
ser humano y que eso que está haciendo
es correcto y válido
como esta persona que ha nacido como un
lienzo en blanco como todos los demás
construye este continuo de la violencia
y la justificación de su acto en un
entorno social
con otros hombres hasta lograr su
cometido
y lo que más me llama la atención de los
casos de femicidio es que tanto víctimas
como victimarios son muy diversos
vienen de todos los grupos sociales
educativos económicos
con sus intersección a lidades con sus
privilegios y con sus discriminaciones
todas diferentes todos diferentes
sin embargo el común denominador de las
víctimas es que mueren por ser mujeres
en manos de un hombre
hoy quisiera invitarlos a que busquemos
y creemos juntos estos espacios
personales y grupales
para reflexionar sobre nuestros
privilegios nuestras conductas lo que
hacemos y lo que no
y es que lo es qué
es lo que creemos
es lo que pensamos cero hombres lo que
nos está afectando no
qué tipo de hombres queremos ser
porque no existe un concepto único de lo
que es el hombre
este problema es de hombres
pero la solución también es de hombres
como hombre
quiero entregar mi privilegio con amor
por la justicia y la igualdad de todas
las personas
muchas gracias